looks good out there by that pool you
know ted it's hot out there you've got a
little bit of cloud cover i was hoping
that might kind of cool us off just a
little bit it hasn't really done much
not much at all we knew that's going to
happen right we knew we're going to get
some cloud cover too but
we knew we're going to get the heat as
well now here's the good news though if
we actually had the
pure sunshine on us yeah it would feel
even hotter but
when you're 100 110 111 even 112
certainly doesn't help much at all so
the official high for the day today 114
degrees
85 overnight 99 is where we should be
the record on this date was 116. i knew
we weren't going to reach it but we
would come close
any time we reach 100 degrees and above
our good friends at silver state
refrigeration and hvac will always
donate 100
to charity and guess what guys you can
be donating a lot of money this week
for sure into next week too current
attempts 111 for sky canyon along with
centennial hills 109 for
spring valley we're at 113 for north las
vegas
that also includes our friends up there
and also downtown
113 sunrise manor and 112 for whitney
ranch mountains edges even 110 degrees
along with rhodes ranch southern
highlands 108 and 110
for henderson regional temperatures look
at death valley right now at 120
degrees currently out there in inyo
county 118 for you in laughlin
113 up there in northeast clark in
mesquite
so monsoon moisture now making its way
up just on the outskirts of phoenix here
in a few pop-up showers to the east in
the four corners region
we remain dry and will remain that dry
for at least a few more days here
clouds are sneaking up wrapping around
that high
that high responsible for the heat and
that's going to move its way
downward and out of the region by the
time we start to get towards the weekend
so that's when the numbers will start to
decline but in the meantime
we're still talking about five days of
extreme heat with that high nearby
and record heat as well there are your
record numbers
lasting all the way through saturday i
think we'll break those records
wednesday and thursday
and possibly tie those records on friday
and saturday
before those numbers start to drop
remember that heat warning
in effect all the way into saturday at 9
p.m
88 degrees overnight we'll have a new
record warm low
we'll have a new record high tomorrow
with 115
besting the other record of 114 setback
in 1940. there'll also be
clouds and sun breaks also for tomorrow
too here are your highs 112 in
centennial hills
114 spring valley 114 southern highlands
113 mountains edge 114 north las vegas
henderson you'll come in 113. green
valley sunrise manor
the hottest spots tomorrow at 117 for a
high
here's where we really get hot death
valley coming in 126
tomorrow in the afternoon and 120 for
those of you in laughlin your eight day
forecast
shows that record heat through saturday
a little bit of relief for dad's day but
not much and then
back down to 104 and near average next
week
that's your most accurate forecast brian
over to you all right ted thank